welcome to my review of wrath of the
Titans one of the most requested sequels
of all time wrath of the Titans star Sam
Worthington Liam Neeson raiffa Hinds
Rosamund Pike all these people are in
this movie and you know it's a big
franchise thing where Clash of the
Titans was actually kind of a moderate
hit financially but most people know
regards to class the Titans it was kind
of like you know it was alright and some
people hated that thing man some people
hated and now we have wrath of the
Titans and as I kind of alluded to in my
intro really not the most necessary
sequel because you know the first one 3d
was terrible most people weren't that
big of fans of it why are we making
another one oh right
Jing now say I'm willing to his back as
per season you know I don't mind Sam
really thing he seems like a really nice
guy I mean he seems like a nice guy
yes he's not the greatest actor alive
but hey neither was Gary Busey and we
all liked him right I mean I like Gary
Busey I've gone really off track I
apologize what I want to say is it's Sam
Worthington ain't that bad this movie he
does a pretty good job as Perseus he's
believable as a physical strong hero and
he does he does well with what he has to
do
basically Zeus has become enslaved his
son and Percy's his brother is now
become this evil guy who just wants to
take over everything and you know the
back story of his villainy isn't really
that delve into it all it's basically
just kind of used as an excuse to have a
villain and have some fun action and
Perseus has to then find and destroy
this guy he has to collect all these
different weapons to make it into one
giant weapon and you know we've seen
this before you collect all these little
things to make one big piece of
something and it's a movie that we've
seen a thousand times before but listen
listen the action in this movie just
listen
this movie is better than Clash the
Titans it is and you know what to be
honest I actually had some fun with this
movie I thought the special effects
sequences were really well done the
special effects were great actually
really got into the action sequences of
this movie they were very well done the
musical score was also really good it
was directed by the same guy who made
battle Los Angeles which going in I was
like what am I about to see and I
enjoyed him more in the first film I did
I thought they stepped up their game in
regards to most things but story of this
film is pretty much written by the same
kid who wrote this means more that
little
that kata just wants to you know I'm
just going to write story and it's not
going to make any sense hopefully we can
get some kind of director who has an
idea of how to shape this into something
entertaining we can make it look good
and they did that I think they did that
really well I mean there are certain
sequence in this movie there are a lot
of fun and really actually pretty
exciting but from a story perspective
don't even bother
don't even try to psychoanalyze this
movie because there's no point and you
will hate it if you're going to go see
where either the Titans just know that
in my opinion it's better than the first
film it has some fun action sequences
and it has a good production value but
everything else is kind of not that
great just deal with that or I just just
let that slide and you'll probably enjoy
yourself I had pretty much the same
thoughts of it as I had with immortals I
thought it was a great looking movie
with really great action but story
not so much nevertheless I did enjoy
watching wrath of the Titans about 65
percent of the time so I'm going to give
it a b-minus I really thought about that
65 percent I really did that took me a
while to come up with that number I
really hope you appreciate the the
thought that went into that it's an okay
movie so you guys may have noticed that
I have a cabin in the woods shirt on I
did see the film last night I can't wait
to tell you my thoughts on it I'll have
that review up very soon look forward to
that I can give you a little hint
Oh until next time guys if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get steppen eyes